[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 débat c'était le 17
novembre dernier près de 300000
personnes portant un gilet jaune se
mobiliser partout en france contre la
hausse du prix des carburants blocages
de ronds-points de routes ou de péage un
mouvement spontané qui a surpris par son
ampleur depuis le gouvernement a annoncé
des mesures un mois plus tard qu'en est
il du mouvement gilet jaune
c est le débat de ce soir et pour y
répondre avec nous en plateau béatrice
et jean marc bonsoir alors vous ne les
portez pas ce soir mais vous êtes
yvelinois et vous avez intégré le
mouvement un gilet jaune en face de vous
et bruno milian bon si vous êtes député
modem de la 9e circonscription des
yvelines président du modem 68 également
et vous soutenez les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement on va y revenir bien
sûr en détail dans quelques minutes mais
pour commencer je me tourne vers vous
béatrice et jean marc et qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé depuis un mois a intégré
le mouvement gilet jaune tout simplement
donc déjà il ya eu l'annoncé de la taxe
le carburant et
on a vu le mouvement sur internet et
c'est vrai qu'on fait peut-être partie
des classes moyennes où on a eu
l'impression encore de se prendre un
coup de massue sur la tête
pour certaines familles c'est assez
compliqué quand bien même on travaille
quand bien même on gagne sa vie et
aujourd'hui ça n'a fait qu'ajouter en
fait c'est du plus et du puce et du plus
est à un moment donné si on dit qui ne
dit rien consent et à un moment donné on
peut plus consentir enfin moi
personnellement je ne consent plus vous
savoir qu'est ce qui vous a poussé et
moi c'est un peu l'absence de consensus
ça fait des années puisque je suis un
peu plus âgés que béatrice que je vois
la france tranquillement s'enfonçait et
les inégalités se creusent et et il ya
un moment où je me suis dit qu il
fallait s'occuper de tout ça et
rejoindre les gens qui avaient décidé de
manifester contre une certaine forme de
fractures beaucoup plus que contre la
taille du carburant alors bruno myle
viennent quelle a été votre réaction le
17 novembre quand vous êtes rendu compte
finalement que ce mouvement le rappelle
ce mouvement qui est né sur internet
eh bien c'était largement concrétiser
dans les rues moi je pense que c'est un
mouvement qui est d'origine beaucoup
plus lointaine que le 17 novembre à pour
être honnête c'est monsieur l'a dit
c'est quelque chose qui est qui revient
de loin je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui revient de
de pas mal d'abandons de manquements au
cours des années notamment des élus je
prends ma part c'est une responsabilité
collective même si à l'époque j'étais
pas lui mais il faut savoir assumer le
fait d'être réduits et et il ya eu trop
d'abandon ces quarante dernières années
soit pas mal de choses on le sait tous
la mondialisation c'est quelque chose
contre lequel il nous est difficile de
combattre si les sites où les chefs des
tables du monde ne combattent pas contre
ça s'est compliqué dans un petit pays
comme la france même si c'est la sixième
ou cinquième ou sixième puissance du
monde
c'est compliqué donc la seule chose
qu'on peut faire pour combattre cette
mondialisation essaie d'éviter qu'elles
broie tout le monde parce que c'est un
peu ça c'est d'arriver à mettre des
barrières de protection et de préserver
et fait effectivement les gens qui sont
dans la précarité et aujourd'hui on a vu
que quand il ya un tassement finalement
notamment au niveau des salaires ça tu
as pas vers le haut sa tasse vers le bas
il ya de plus de plus de gens qui se
retrouvent je sais pas si c'est votre
table et en tout cas à la lisière d'un
déclassement dont ils ne veulent pas
entendre parler ils ont bien raison
donc notre boulot là où on a failli
c'est qu'on n'a pas su mettre en place
personne n'a su mettre en place jusqu'à
vannes n'est pas su assez écouté les
français c'est le ras-le-bol finalement
de 102 députés
non c'est pas qu'on les a pas écoutés on
les a écoutés mais on n'a pas mis des
choses en place ça c'est sûr qu'on n'a
pas mis des choses en place
il ya eu des amants dont il ya eu des
lâchetés la part des gouvernements on a
bien vu à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
réformes qu'on aurait dû faire pour
effectivement essayé d'arriver à faire
les choses dès qu'il y avait une grosse
manifestation c'était on bat en bas en
arrière complètement et surtout on fait
plus rien du quinquennat pour pas voir
dans merde parce que il ya des élections
derrière c'est pas ça le rôle de l'élu
le rôle de l'élu c'est davies dc
d'assumer effectivement concertation
avec les gens un certain nombre de
changements
là il faut vraiment qu'on écoute les
gens parce que la colère elle est
partout on la sentait monter
honnêtement je n'ai trop net je pensais
pas qu'elle exploserait de cette manière
là mais à la limite si on doit tirer
quelque chose de bénéfique de cette
colère qu'a exposé c'est qu'aujourd'hui
oui vraiment il faut qu'on se mette
autour de la table avec ce mouvement là
avec le mouvement d'elie gilet jaune et
avec les gens qui ont des vraies
difficultés c'est pas c'est pas juste
c'est pas du cinéma après il y en a qui
sont petites politisée a d'autres qui
ont été récupérés peu importe
faut mettre tout sur la table des
solutions qui ont été avancées alors il
ya eu évidemment des blocages quotidien
sur les ronds-points vous avez vous
participé à ces blocages de ronds-points
notamment du côté de coignières par
exemple on a fait du côté de coignières
on a fait le péage de saint-arnoult
aussi en gratuité pour pouvoir laisser
passer les véhicules ce qui leur a
permis de monter sur paris et coignières
notamment où on a fait plus un filtrage
qu'un blocage
ceci afin de pas trop gêné non plus les
riverains qui était quitterait qui
habitait au tour et potentiellement bien
nous faire mener sur l'état disent aussi
sur l'a12 on était aussi en filtrage
depuis le premier jour à part la
première matinée où effectivement
n'était en opération escargot donc là on
pouvait considérer qu ont bloqué un qu
on a toujours été en filtrage on a
toujours laissé passer les gens et on a
aussi toujours été soucieux de faire en
sorte que tous les services de secours
s'il y avait besoin d'eux puisse passer
sans délai vous avez manifesté sur les
champs elysées n'ont pas encore d'accord
vous êtes pour l'instant rester
uniquement dans les yvelines savourer ça
pourrait venir
moi je suis partisan de monter sur paris
mais pour des raisons personnelles on ne
fait pas alors le 10 décembre
emmanuel macron a appris est la parole a
annoncé un certain nombre de mesures
on le fait on verra le détail d'ailleurs
dans quelques instants le projet de loi
concrétisant à ces mesures a été
présenté d'ailleurs ce matin en conseil
des ministres bruno myle yens pourquoi
le président at il été aussi long à
s'exprimer à annoncer des mesures
concrètes pourquoi cette réponse at elle
tardé
je suis pas le président je suis bien
incapable de vous le dire je pense que
il ya eu deux choses aient eu d'abord
une phase où on essayait de voir comment
on pouvait négocier finalement négocié
ou en tout cas recueillir
les combles et doléances pardon je
fatigue et recueillir les doléances
gilet jaune via des représentants
qui ce qui aurait été légitime sur sur
toute la france pour comment on puisse
discuter au moins avec le premier
ministre que ça remonte et qu'on voit
exactement quelle est la nature des
besoins en tout cas la nature de
l'urgence des besoins parce qu'il faut
les prioriser il ya tout un tas de
choses que vous réclamez il ya des
choses qui sont plus prioritaires que
d'autres et fallait les caractériser ça
n'a pas pu se faire
donc c'est ça a pris du temps et puis au
bout d'un moment ben ça prend tellement
de temps on a vu ce qui s'est passé à
paris qu'à un moment pour prendre la
décision et en espérant qu'on tape au
bon endroit
alors justement ces annonces il ya
notamment l'augmentation de 100 euros à
du smic la défisc il des fêtes v
défiscalisation je vais y arriver elle
des heures supplémentaires l'annulation
de la hausse de la csg en 2019 pour les
retraités
béatrice et jean marc quel a été votre
réaction quand devant votre télé vous
avez vous avez entendu ces annonces du
président tu n'étais pas devant ma télé
on écoutait discours à coignières avec
l'équipe des gilet jaune et je peux vous
dire que ça a été très très mal
accueillie puisque on sait bien douté
enfin pour avoir des parents retraités
autour de nous une annulation de hausse
d'accord mais ça les aidera pas à vivre
mieux
malheureusement c'est bien qu'on peut
pas augmenter tout le monde mais à un
moment donné on ne peut pas non plus
laisser non plus ancien dans certains
états financiers dans lequel il se
trouve aujourd'hui à pas pouvoir se
chauffer il doit pas pouvoir manger ça
c'est juste quelque chose qu'on ne veut
on peut pas entendre en tout cas venant
de notre part quant à l'augmentation des
100 euros faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
toutes les classes moyennes valant n'en
bénéficieront pas non plus donc il n'y a
qu'une partie de la population qui
pourra en bénéficier
moi personnellement j'ai beau faire tous
les calculs je paie des impôts je gagne
1 pas un mauvais salaires aujourd'hui je
fais pas partie des plus mais par contre
je sais que je paie ça y'a pas de soucis
sur le sur le sujet et je ne demande pas
une augmentation mais au moins revoir au
niveau des taxes qu'on paye des taxes
comme ont le don
dit et on le souligne on paye des taxes
sur les taxes on a des taxes sur l'eau
et on nous rajoute une tva derrière je
travaille dans la grande distribution
je vois bien des taxes sur les
marchandises et on our taxes la tva
dessus par contre une remise vous
l'aurez jamais sur la taxe est interdit
par la loi et on doit s'y tenir
mais à un moment donné il faut juste
nous dire stop
alors je vous propose on va y revenir
évidemment sur ces annonces juste des de
regarder les réactions d'autres
yvelinois justement à l'annoncé des
mesures d' emmanuel macron c'est trop
peu trop tard beau les annonces
j'attends les réalités les annonces et
c'est joli à faire mais bon maintenant
voir ce qui est vraiment mis en place
après et qui va en profiter parce
qu'apparemment entre les annonces qui a
eu et l'application bon il ya déjà des
gens qui déchantent bas sur le coup on
dit c'est super puis quand on analyse on
se rend compte que finalement il ya peu
de gens qui vont toucher ce qu'il a
promis c'est du bidon
seedorf images ont fait des annonces
mais finalement derrière les gens ont
l'impression d'être floués
il faut que le mouvement continue parce
que ça touche un petit peu tout le monde
c'est moi je parle notamment au niveau
des retraités on a subi une baisse de
des retraites une augmentation des
impôts parce que par exemple je suis
veuve on a supprimé la demi part
supplémentaire ce qui me fait presque
doubler mes impôts enfin bon c'est voilà
quoi il faut il faut que ça devienne j
wable bruno myle viennent on vient
d'entendre notamment une retraitée cette
annulation de la hausse de la csg pour
les retraités fait débat puisqu'elle ne
sera pas tout de suite effective puisque
le porter ce maillot
voilà vraiment rembourser voilà mais
pourquoi pourquoi finale parce que
techniquement c'est pas possible je sais
je sais pas vous expliquez moi je suis
pas dans l'est
les dans les rouages de de ces
versements là c'était techniquement pas
possible le premier ministre voulait
vraiment que ce soit dès le mois de
janvier c'est impossible donc au mieux
on va faire le plus vite possible donc
on part on annonce avril mai ou juin
on va faire le plus tôt on va essayer
d'approcher d'avril et après ce qu'il
n'aura pas été déduit corps a été payé
en tout cas jusqu'à ce qu'on remboursera
intégralement remboursé on va être
d'accord sur un point je pense c'est que
les mesures qu'ils soient avancées sont
des mesures d'urgence sur le sur le smic
qu'on appelle à tort le smic d'ailleurs
je voudrais être honnête on peut appeler
ça finalement c'est la prime serait une
excellente réactivité qui revalorise et
en plus de la revalorisation automatique
du smic
ça va quand même concerner 5 millions de
foyers donc moi je veux bien que ça
concerne peu de personnes au total ça va
quand même concerner 5 million de foyers
alors avec des choses qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à pour un couple avec deux enfants
en fonction de leurs revenus
pour aller jusqu'à 200 euros par mois
une femme les femmes seules notamment
avec avec des enfants à charge
là c'est pareil c'est un truc je vais
juste une parenthèse c'est un truc qu'on
a découvert avec les cahiers de
doléances des mères c'est qu'on
s'imaginait pas qu'il y ait autant de
familles monoparentales
bah oui parce que les statistiques elles
sortent pas forcément tout le temps et
on s'en rend pas forcément compte
on savait que j'en avais on savait que
c'était difficile mais à ce point là
voilà moins ça nous ouvre les yeux sur
des choses qu'on n'avait pas vue et pour
les familles monoparentales ça va
jusqu'à une fois une avec 7 smic
comment toucher le pour toucher 200
euros supplémentaires donc c'est pas le
smic en réalité c'est pas le smic
pourquoi pas si c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
a été reproché
on va revenir si vous permettez c'est un
peu technique mais je vais essayer
d'être le plus clair possible on va
revenir en 2014
en 2014 il avait été décidé de faire
justement une augmentation enfin une
augmentation du smic via la suppression
de certaines cotisations sociales à
l'époque c'était sous françois hollande
la loi est votée elle passe en conseil
constitutionnel elle est recalée bien il
faut qu'on change la constitution
ça c'est votre problème en toi en état
actuel de la constitution
elle est recalée parce qu'on ne peut pas
faire de différence entre différentes
catégories de salariés
c'est soit on supprime et pour tout le
monde ou de ce qui était le plus dans la
précarité
jusqu'à ce qu'ils gagnent très bien leur
vie et là il y avait quand même comme
une forme d'injustice sociale pour que
la puissance et c'est parce que cette
jurisprudence existe parce que cette
piste la halle est envisagée elle était
simple tous a rajouté 100 euros partout
à tous les gens qui aiment le smic mais
du coup on prenait pas en compte non
plus le foyer fiscal et des gens qui se
retrouvaient à 1,7 smic et c'est à qui
vont bénéficier de la mesure
donc c'est pas forcément la solution
idéale serait en train de vous dire mais
en tout cas pour être rapide pour être
opérationnel le plus rapidement possible
c'est la seule qu'on m'avait à
disposition jean-marc suit donc à ces
annonces du gouvernement on peut dire
quand même que le gouvernement a fait un
pas vers vers vous mais vous n'êtes
toujours pas satisfait qu'est ce que
vous attendez de plus disons que tonton
regarde déjà froidement les gens
rsa les chômeurs ils sont toujours
dans le même état si sans oublier qu'ils
sont totalement oubliés par les par les
mesures qui ont été annoncées
les 100 euros de prime supplémentaire
c'est bien mais à priori c'est une
anticipation de choses qui étaient déjà
prévus c'est par un vrai cadeau on a eu
aussi la prime de fin d'année qui est
assez aléatoire puisqu'elles dépendent
les intérêts des employeurs et qui par
ailleurs on nous a dit gentiment et
qu'elle était
m d'impôts comme 2018 est une année
blanche on a un peu l'impression aussi
que
[Musique]
l'honnêteté n'était pas au rendez vous
l'élève d'accoster sur des cotisations
c'est à dire que vous touchez 800 sont
vous donne 850 vous touchez une licence
à continuer tel qu'un bon an mal an
c'est le patron vous en rougit dans les
cortèges également on a vu notamment
samedi dernier des pancartes parlant du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne vous
partagez cet avis alors j'ai un avis qui
est un peu partagé justement par rapport
au référendum au référendum d'initiative
citoyenne c'est quelque chose qui marche
apparemment très bien
la france n'est pas la suisse on est
déjà un peu plus nombreux et surtout les
plus principal problème qu'on a sur les
élections depuis un certain temps c'est
que les élections sont quand même
largement une télé guidé par les médias
à mon sens depuis mitterrand et depuis
notre ami jacques séguéla donc mettre en
place des votes
oui mais comment fait-on pour qui ce
vote soit vraiment des votes citoyens et
non pas des votes qui ont été
téléguidées par la machine médiatique
vous êtes pour vous ce référendum
d'initiative
moi je suis pas contre sûr je suis
contre rien qui viennent de solutions
dans ma parce que beaucoup de solutions
qu'on peut emmener dans des programmes
qu'ils soient municipaux ou
intercommunaux ou même au niveau de
l'état viennent souvent des idées qui
sont bonnes en bas du bon sens qu'on va
dire et d'orchidées bientôt a dit qu'il
était plutôt ouvert alors on est ouvert
mais vous voyez bien que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut donc il va falloir
qu'on discute justement avec le
mouvement pour faire les choses de
manière à la fois équitable est
souhaitable pour tous chevaux prend un
exemple simple si on reste sur les bases
qui sont ici défini que je peux voir
mois sur les cahiers de doléances à sept
cent mille habitants pour relancer un
fait dans un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne je prends n'importe quoi moi
je que je connais certaines personnes
qui sont un petit peu plus radicalisés
avec moi on peut très bien de ma revenir
sur le droit à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
par exemple on peut revenir sur
l'interdiction de la peine de mort on
peut revenir sur des choses comme ça qui
sont dangereux donc c'est vraiment c'est
un sujet important sur lequel
effectivement il faut qu'on travaille
avec eux de manière mais absolument
tranquille détendu et et qu'on avance
là-dessus mais attention à ne pas tomber
dans un truc d'abord qui feraient la loi
à la place de la loi parce que c'est pas
le but qu'ils seraient capables de
défaire des lois qui ont été votées qui
étaient plutôt des acquis parce que ça
c'est le risque aussi sait quel sens
cela je vous parlais de la peine de mort
et bill et j'ai donc il faut quand même
faire attention sur ce sur sur ce sur
quoi on s'engage
après je pense que ça peut être très
intéressant notamment sur des questions
sociétales
alors cette émission touche bientôt à sa
fin les fêtes arrivent
est-ce que vous allez toujours être
mobilisés parce que c'est prévu pour ma
part oui on est sur des groupes qui y
tiennent
passer les fêtes et on sera quand même
mobilisé puisque si enfin on ne peut pas
moi personnellement je ne vois pas me
désengager juste parce que c'est les
fêtes et je prendrai un exemple qui a
été très probants pour l'élection de
monsieur macron fil des présidentielles
seront tombés durant des week-end pascal
et on a eu une désertification on a eu
une désertification je suis électrices
et j'ai été dans les zones de voter on a
une désertification des gens moi là je
veux me disent ils c'est pas parce que
ça va être les fêtes que je vais me
démobilisés du mouvement pour passer les
fêtes non
jean-marc il y aurait donc un acte 6 par
exemple ce samedi ce n'est pas moi qui
décide mais oui vraisemblablement et je
dirais que l'intérêt général c'est que
le mouvement continue
si jamais le mouvement s'éteignait je ré
réellement peur qu'il ne ressorte dans
quelques temps mais nettement moins
convivial je dirais qu'il ne l'est pour
le moment
même s'il ya quelques incidents par
endroits jusqu'au compteur rouge pour
l'acte 6 il n'y a pas de problème dans
le calme etc
je vous dis quand même fait attention
quand vous montez à paris parce que vous
êtes amalgamé avec des gens avec
lesquels vous n'avez rien à faire et qui
du coup vous desservent je vous le dis
quand même c'est honnête de ma part et
je vous donne rendez-vous à partir du
mois de janvier
un petit peu partout dans ma
circonscription pour ceux qui seront
dans ma circonscription parce qu'on
ouvrira des salles des fêtes avec les
maires ruraux pour écouter les doléances
des gilet jaune et on va faire le boulot
que nous a demandé le gouvernement mais
peut-être même en plus de ce que nous
avons un gouvernement c'est notre
mission
merci à tous les trois d'avoir été à
présent pour cette fuite débat voilà les
missions à touche à sa fin et merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve le 9
janvier pour un nouveau 7,8 débat en
attendant passé et d'excellentes fêtes
de fin d'année
[Musique]